it's the most wonderful time of the year
the twelve thousand and twenty human
space era calendar has arrived you can
order it now until we sell out and then
never again in the last few years we've
looked back at the achievements of our
ancestors that paved the way for our
modern world more than ten thousand
years ago this year we'll turn our gaze
to the future of humanity and how we
will explore space in the next ten
thousand years twelve illustrations will
take you to the liquid gas oceans on
Titan colonies on Mars the storm clouds
on Uranus and many more stops on
humanity's biggest journey yet enjoy
solar system wide delivery shipping for
the US and finally also from Europe
order now to get our limited-edition
calendar in time for the holidays to
make your kids family and friends happy
or to distress yourself from the looming
void within you know whatever works for
you you can get the calendar together
with a duck plushie a hoodie or a poster
if you want we've put together a few
deals thank you so much to the thousands
of people who got the calendar last year
because of you we can keep this channel
free for everyone and make even more
beautiful things a happy intersted a
year twelve thousand and twenty
[Music]